congratulations to
yada yada molina the 39 year old
nine-time gold glover four-time platinum
glove winner 10-time national league
all-star and now under his belt
a contract extension for next season
congratulations to the cardinals and
toyati jack flaherty gets the start he
has made 13 starts this year 9-1 record
he's been dominant the walk strikeout
ratio is very good he's around the plate
his stuff has been really as consistent
as anybody in baseball but do an 809 ops
right around that 800 mark so good
numbers 267 10 home runs the 2-1 pitch
lines it into center bader diving and
what a way to strike the game a diving
catch harrison better in center i feel
as if i was just watching a replay
except i'm watching it live i've seen
this play how many times dan 10 times
this year a dive from harrison bader a
divot to replace
and just the gutsiness to be able to
catch the ball and hold on very very
agile play by vader casey mize and one
of the things that he's working on or
he'll have to have today that fastball
command
since august 1st goldsmith is hitting
355 with 11 multi-hit games
2-2 wave and a miss and the first
strikeout of the night for casey mize
comes against paul goldsmith
that's really good location there by
casey mize that ball starts on the outer
third and all of a sudden when it gets
to the plate you see that ball just kind
of take a left turn derrick hill the
eighth place batter in the lineup for
detroit the o2
right back up the middle on a base hit
derek hill comes through
bader charging throwing home
it's up the line and they throw down the
third but harold castro is there one run
scores but it's a big clutch 02 pitch
smoked right back up the middle by
derrick hill to get the tigers on the
board guys we talked about flaherty
struggling with his command trying to go
away but that ball leaks right back over
the plate not a really good o2 pitch
right over the heart of plate and
derrick hill lines that ball right back
up the middle
driving the tigers first run it's a good
piece of hitting there by derrick hill
been such a good approach by him lately
3-0 to casey mize
and he walked him on four straight
mize's first played appearance brings
home a run and the tigers lead it two
nothing
how about the bat flip there chef do you
like that um he's not going to put it on
his highlight reel let's put it that way
jonathan scope grounded two-second first
time up
ground ball to short
and the young will flip to tommy edmond
and the tigers scratch out a couple of
runs and settle for two but strand three
tigers with a couple of runs off jack
flaherty in the second grossman leads
off he struck out his first time up 2-1
to grossman a drive deep right field
that ball's gone into the saint louis
bullpen and robbie grossman belts number
19 on the year to lead off the third
flaherty struggling with command falls
but falls behind in the count
two and one look at the pitch here right
over the heart of the plate down in that
lefty's happy zone and robbie grossman
greets him he's just tied eric haas for
the team lead with 19 bombs here's
miguel cabrera
strips one to deep left field that ball
is gone in the third deck
number 501 was crushed
miguel cabrera gets himself a hanging
slider here
and with his approach he's always
thinking right center with the fastball
and flaherty speeds up his bet and
that's big mac land in st louis that was
annihilated
grossman and cabrera go back to back i
don't know if jack's not feeling strong
in this game or or what's going on but
it looks like he's going to ask for the
baseball and he does that's it for jack
flaherty and right shoulder tightness
for jack palarity and taken out of the
game so miller two on one out and facing
castro
miller's got it fires to second and it's
a double play
one six three on the double play tigers
have a four nothing lead in the first of
two the cardinals funkhouser pitching
two three four hitters here in the sixth
inning
the one two swinging a miss
that's the stuff we're talking about
fastball riding
two up and two down
the two is swinging in the mist he over
powered nolan arnotto fastball right by
him good inning kyle funkhouser
cardinals with just four hits tonight
they've been out hit 6-4 it's bader the
1-1
and bader shoots the gap in right center
off to the races
all the way to the wall vader to second
now on his way to third the relay is not
in time
triple for harrison vader no way that uh
you can keep up with harrison bater
first triple of the year and now it is
joseph
just off the plate runners at the
corners
and nobody out shift here for tommy
edmond he's been on base twice base hit
to center stolen base walked and
grounded out
hit into
the shift and with sosa speed no chance
to turn two that's a nice play at short
run does score edmond brings in his 36
then the cardinals get on the board to
make it 4-1
but that was a tough play
at short with a shift by short and
nobody at second base anyway even if you
wanted to throw it to somebody nobody
nobody at home here's the play
he's the shortstop so who who do you
throw it to
only play is at first base and look at
the hands there by short that's
impressive very easily could have gotten
past him rough home stand for nolan
arenado that could change with one swing
of the bat
and that's a base hit down into the
right field corner one run will score
that's sosa carlson being waved in
auronado has made this a one-run
game
what a great two-strike approach for
arnaud i was just about to say
don't need the home run i'd take a
double i didn't have to say it it just
happened
pitch up and away
the short stroke
down the right field lying
and the cardinals now have the tying run
at second base they haven't made a lot
of noise but now they are
first time bader has faced michael
fulmer in his career
the 0-1
sharply to second
tigers win it 4-3
michael former with his eighth save of
the season
the good vibes continue for detroit in
st louis